vous connaissez la capitale
bourguignonne vous connaissiez dijon oui
bon je n'aurais pu tout aussi bien se
balader à besançon ce matin ne
choisissons dijon parce qu'il ya
actuellement des visites insolites que
nous vous proposons avec claire lequien
et quand on dit insolite c'est pas peu
dire c'est des visites un petit peu
spécial québécois se lie d c'était de
mélanger de finalement différentes
activités avec le patrimoine
voilà voilà longtemps différents on voit
par exemple ici une photo très
particulières expliqué moins de quoi il
s'est fait en fait là c'était au sein du
musée d'art sacré donc qui se trouve à
dijon rue sainte-anne et que tout le
monde connaît ou presque parce que il a
un dôme vert 1 ce musée c'était une
ancienne église mais on sait pas
toujours ce que c'est on n'ose pas
toujours y rentrer donc là l'idée
c'était de faire un peu de renforcement
musculaire au sein de ce musée
donc on découvre quand même un petit peu
le lieu pas trop longtemps c'est pas
l'objectif de connaître parfaitement le
dieu on s'est juste un petit peu où on
se trouve et puis après bien on se
laisse prendre aussi à une initiation
effectivement sportive dans ce cadre là
ne passera pas toujours du sport 1 mais
là c'était effectivement du sport qui
étaient réalisés ici bas justement il ya
d'autres exemples qu'on va découvrir
d'ici quelques minutes mais d'abord les
visites c'est aussi balle le patrimoine
j'allais dire plus classique qui se
cache finalement à tous les coins de rue
dans le centre historique de dijon
la preuve en couleurs et sous le soleil
avec une visite des plus classiques je
vous propose de suivre le guide
puis nous revenons pour des visites
insolites regarder
la visite commence à l'office de
tourisme exactement à la chapelle des
élus recoins méconnus du palais des ducs
et des états de bourgogne une salle aux
murs flanqué de gigantesques porte aussi
belle que grande qu'inutile elle ne
s'ouvre sur rien d'ailleurs elle ne
s'ouvre pas elles ne sont là que pour
donner la symétrie au véritable porte
d'en face c'est l'une des petites
histoires que frédéric re moissenet
raconte au fil des rues du centre
historique de dijon
une balade qui va très vite s'arrêter
devant notre-dame au pied de la façade
et de son jacquemart l'histoire de cette
drôle d'horloge nous ramène en 13 169
philippe le hardi duc de bourgogne
épouse marguerite de flandre et ça n'est
pas un cadeau du moins pas comme on
l'entend tous les contemporains de dame
marguerite s'accordent à dire que c'est
une véritable mauges t1 et draw mais les
riches
donc quiconque obtiendra la main de dame
marguerite la moche et la riche aura des
territoires à la clé l'artois les
flandres qui prospérait du drap c'est
philippe le hardi duc de bourgogne qui
décroche la timbale essai de belgique
que le duc ramènera le jacquemart il
fondera ici sa famille jacqueline vient
le rejoindre au 17e union de laquelle
naîtront jacqueline et au 18e puis
jacqueline est au 19e et tandis que la
famille se partagent mes heures demi
heure et quart d'heure a sonné les
gargouilles juste en dessous ne crache
toujours pas d'eau leur rôle depuis le
moyen-âge a toujours été décoratifs dans
le quartier passage obligé devant la
chouette elle porte bonheur on la touche
et on garde son voeu pour soi sinon la
salamandre tout proche pourrait bien la
vallée salamandre emblème de françois
1er
d'ordinaire coiffé d'une couronne alors
ouais la chorale royal
en dessous du vitrail il suffisait de
regarder d'un peu plus près comme pour
s'apercevoir qu'ils s'y naquit la
grand-mère de la marquise de sévigné ou
bien que la cette maison n'a plus de
toit
la maison d'un pâtissier à une époque où
des enfants disparaissait
mystérieusement ses pâtés à la viande
firent la fortune de monsieur karklins
il avait beaucoup de succès jusqu'à ce
que la joue pas comme un autre
un client découvrir un morceau de doigt
dans son pâté ont compris très vite que
monsieur carte la fabrique à ses pattes
et à partir de la chair des enfants
disparus
le toit de sa maison fut rasée en signe
de déshonneur et l'homme supplicié en
place publique voilà comment en quelques
milliers d'années d'existence
dijon a forgé ses secrets elle en a
dévoilé quelques uns élan garde
forcément bien de ces petits pâtés à la
viande ce genre de secrets gourmands
quand même qui fait froid dans le dos
bon des anecdotes des faits divers des
les gens y en a dans les visites
classiques mais il ya aussi les visites
insolites dans la capitale bourguignonne
actuellement on a fait un petit peu de
sport tout à l'heure qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire d'autre a alors on va en fait
on proposait tous les mois donc ça sera
à chaque fois dans des lieux différents
avec des activités différentes
c'est quand même souvent du sport
j'avoue on a quand même souvent été
ciblé le public qui est apprécié quand
même aussi le sport là donc on a l'image
effectivement de la caserne heudelet
l'ancienne caserne de l'est qui a été
réhabilitée et qui aujourd'hui le siège
de dijon métropole et on va y faire de
l'escrimé avec arman ben oui carrément
mais c'est aussi en fait en lien avec ce
qu'était la caserne 1 c'était le 26e
dragon
le régiment du 26e dragons qui
effectivement aussi ils pouvaient donc
combattre à pied avec des lances et
c'est donc on se rapproche aussi
effectivement est bien de l'histoire du
lieu mais on comprenne bon on n'aura pas
le maire de dijon et pour nous faire la
visite parce que là c'est le siège de
dijon métropole vous le disait fort
justement ça se passe comment quel est
l'intérêt finalement de faire de
l'escrim dans un lieu comme ça et là
l'intérêt c'est de vivre son patrimoine
il ya beaucoup d'endroits finalement du
rugby l'échec des échoppes vendant vous
savez que c'est vrai j'ai plein d'autres
choses
on aurait pu faire d'autres choses mais
l'idée c'était vraiment de faire presque
choqué un petit peu de faire des
activités décalé pour aussi attirer un
nouveau public
on veut pas être dans la visite
classique en effet où on a on en fait
toujours parce que il ya toujours des
gens que ça intéresse beaucoup
évidemment et il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire mais ça c'est vraiment une première
découverte un bien sûr où on va associer
voilà une pratique sportive artistique
avec le lieu c'est une manière de vivre
différemment son patrimoine et que
chacun puisse se l'approprier
parce que je peux dire que beaucoup de
dijonnais ou même ordre dijonnais entre
métro place sur toute la bourgogne
franche comté alain qui est avec nous et
plus encore sur les écrans connectés sur
france 3 point fr on se dit tiens on
peut aller visiter une capitale
régionale c'est sympa on connaît les
visites classiques on en a vu
quelques-unes là en images dans un
reportage qu'on est beaucoup moins ces
visites insolites ou cet effet elles
sont nouvelles
mais c'est pas mal du tout j'ai même
entendu dire qu'il y avait des dessins
qui était fait aussi dans certains
jardins
alors on va faire effectivement du
dessin dans cette salle ici c'est la
salle des actes alors la salle des actes
on la connaît peu c'était en fait
autrefois dans l'ancien rectorat donc
qui a déménagé depuis et c'est vrai que
quand c'était le rectorat on avait peu
l'occasion de rentrer évidemment à
l'intérieur de ce bâtiment et on est ici
face en fait à un hôtel particulier et
avec une décoration ici du xviie siècle
qui est quand même assez magnifique et
donc là on va vraiment mal à prendre le
temps d'observer de faire du dessin pour
vraiment découvrir ce lieu alors ici il
ne s'agit pas de savoir déjà dessiné
avant de venir c'est vraiment aussi
quelque chose de très simple c'est une
initiation pour parler clair on a vu
tout à l'heure à un guide dans un
reportage on sait que les visites
guidées sont pas forcément gratuite
celles ci sont gratuites ça se passe
comment oui ici effectivement toutes les
activités proposées sont gratuites
elles sont ouvertes à tous alors souvent
quand même pour les insolites
on dit que c'est à partir de 12 ans
parce que plus petit évidemment c'est
difficile d'adapter parfois à la
pratique sportive
évidemment aux enfants donc voilà on dit
à partir de 12 ans mais sinon c'est
ouvert à tout le monde c'est gratuit sur
inscription au lieu d'un solide tiens
moi j'associe la vapeur à la musique ça
veut dire que dans votre visite insolite
dans votre nice matin je fais des
liaisons bizarre où la loi ça glisse un
peu hein
je disais donc on associe souvent la
vapeur la musique c'est une visite
insolite
oui c'est une visite insolite alors
c'est une visite insolite aussi parce
que souvent quand on pense patrimoine on
pense plutôt patrimoine ancien et nous
on s'intéresse pas uniquement à ce qui
est ancien même si on a vraiment un
large et patrimoine un riche patrimoine
à dijon assez exceptionnel sur ce temps
sur ce plan là mais c'est aussi tout ce
qui est architecture 1 et architecture
contemporaine donc là la vapeur qui a
été rénové y'a pas longtemps qui est
réouvert effectivement cette année ça
permet de découvrir le lieu
donc c'est la première partie de cette
insolite et puis ensuite comme on est
dans un lieu de musique
eh ben on va faire de la musique gym ça
ça va faire plaisir à ma femme en dire
plus et bien en fait on va effectivement
c'est une sorte de de gym en musique si
vous voulez hein donc on va être au sein
même de la vapeur on va essayer de
s'arranger aussi avec un équipe de la
vapeur pour passer certains morceaux
évidemment peut-être d'artistes qui vont
arriver par la suite pour pouvoir
effectivement et bien proposer une
activité comme ça un peu décalée de
découverte possède la gc l'onyx ans
véronique et davina
c'est ça cette affaire pourquoi pas
toxique citizen oui parce que ça d'avoir
accompagné par la datar ok c'est un duo
dijonnais qui mêle rap et électro à pour
être très précis vous nous en dire plus
d'ici quelques minutes
on retrouve évidemment toutes les
visites insolites sur le patrimoine
dijonnais sur un petit site internet on
t'a patrimoine dijon.fr un petit tour
dans tous les bons moteurs de recherche
et on retrouve ces visites gratuites
oui tous insistent parce que ça c'est un
mot qui nous plaît voilà des rendez vous
insolites à découvrir sur le net on va
mettre tout ça sur france 3 point fr
évidemment